failed Arizona
Republican gubernatorial candidate Kerry
lake is panicking and deleting tweets
this when I imagine someone deleting
tweets even if they're doing it on their
phone I imagine them feverishly typing
on a keyboard but that may not be the
case she is panicking and deleting
tweets attacking a judge after sanctions
have been demanded so let's back it up
and kind of explain all of it uh Carey
Lake lost the Arizona gubernatorial
election and what I mean by lost is her
opponent Katie Hobbs got more votes
because more people voted for Katie
Hobbs which means Katie Hobbs will be
the governor very simple and yet so
complicated okay she won Kerry Lake lost
Carrie like sues claiming really she won
her lawsuit was thrown out
and now she's just getting herself into
more and more and more trouble the hill
reports Lake deletes tweet targeting
Maricopa judge after officials seek
sanctions defeated Arizona gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake deleted a tweet
accusing the judge who dismissed her
election challenge of Integrity
violations the Tweet posted early Monday
suggested the founding partner of a law
firm representing Katie Hobbs emailed
Maricopa County superior court judge
Peter Thompson what to say as he
authored the dismissal that's an
extremely serious charge to make against
the judge that someone wrote to him and
said
here's your marching orders here's what
decision you will make in court
uh quote the dismissal of Kerry Lake's
election lawsuit shows voter
disenfranchisement no longer matters
um this is her tweet legal experts
believe his decision was Ghost written
they suspect top left-wing attorneys
like Mark Elias emailed him what to say
Maricopa County and Hobbes in their
capacities as Secretary of State and
governor-elect cited the tweet in asking
the judge to impose sanctions on Lake as
well as on her attorneys arguing that
Lakes Lakes campaign's broader election
challenge was groundless and constituted
harassment so what is it that is going
on here she is an annoyance yes but she
is an annoyance to a degree that may
actually deserve legal sanctions and so
she's panicking and so now she's
deleting the Tweet now as much as I
would love to see serious sanctions
against Carrie Lake you know the Wright
loves to talk about frivolous lawsuits
oh the coffee was too hot turns out that
was actually a lawsuit that had some
Merit if you actually learn about it oh
someone said Merry Christmas to me and
I'm offended I don't know of any lawsuit
like that but this is the caricature of
the right and the so-called frivolous
lawsuits they believe the left is
engaged in even though we have many
systems in place to dismiss frivolous
lawsuits but it is actually they who
have no hesitation they have no qualms
whatsoever
um gumming up the legal system after
2020 with more than 60 different
complaints and all sorts of different
jurisdictions for nothing for nothing
Trump lost that's all that happened and
similarly Kerry Lake raising money
filing lawsuits hiring lawyers bringing
in experts taking up court time
for something that is obviously
meritless and is of course going
absolutely nowhere and now they're
panicking that they might uh be
sanctioned if there is any good news for
Kerry Lake and this sort of bugs me but
it is what's going on it's not really
clear that she is going to face those
sanctions uh Fox news reports Arizona
judge denies requests for sanctions
against Lake and rewards a 33 000
reimbursement
an Arizona judge denied a request from
governor-elect Katie Hobbs seeking
sanctions against Kerry Lake though the
sanctions were denied the judge did
award Hobbes a little more than thirty
three thousand dollars to cover costs
associated with retaining expert
Witnesses during a two-day trial brought
on by Lake challenging those results
Lake lost her bid by half a percentage
Point etc etc okay so at least in this
first finding a judge is not issuing
sanctions against Carey Lake
um what you have to understand here
is that there is a mishmash of political
stuff for lack of that's a technical
term going on in Arizona which includes
right thinking and clear-minded people
who see the entire Cary Lake Fiasco for
what it is terrible candidate lost
panicked is embarrassed and is trying to
sue anyone she can
but you also see some judges in Arizona
that are running a little bit of
interference for Cary Lake saying listen
we believe she sincerely believed that
she won and if Kerry Lake sincerely
believed she won
then most of her actions are acceptable
in the eyes of the law it's sort of like
covering for a toddler's temper tantrum
arguing this particular one was
justified and thus everything they did
in all of the sequel a that resulted
from that tantrum uh are okay and we
shouldn't be too harsh as a result
how can someone like Carrie Lake be
considered a good candidate to lead
anything in government whether it's it
being the administrator of a state like
Arizona or whatever when she can't even
control her own impulses on Twitter such
that they start getting her into
potential legal trouble and then she has
to run and delete the tweets but it
doesn't really matter that's really been
Republicans for the last six years who
are the worst people we could possibly
find to do the jobs that are needed
let's make them our nominees
um many of my lawyer friends especially
those that do criminal defense say that
it is really really common that their
clients just can't stop talking or they
won't stop talking either to the media
or recently in the modern era more often
social media posts and to some degree
that seems to be what's going on here
with Kerry Lake let's hope she does face
sanctions let's hope her attorneys do as
well